en el vídeo pasado completamos la
meiosis 1 recuerdas y justo ahora
estamos listos para ir a la meiosis 2 y
a lo mejor te estás preguntando hype
después de la mitosis las células
regresan a un periodo de interfase
existirá también un periodo de descanso
entre las dos fases de la meiosis
la respuesta es a veces puede haber un
periodo de descanso donde hay una
interfase 2 y esto dependerá del tipo de
célula y la especie y todo eso pero es
posible por lo que lo voy a poner aquí
entonces aquí tengo un periodo el cual
llamaremos interfase 2
de fase 2 y bueno va a ser un periodo de
descanso lo puedes ver como eso pero
después las células entran a la meiosis
2 que nos va a ayudar a completar todo
el proceso de la meiosis y como puedes
imaginarte la meiosis 2 comienza con una
etapa llamada pro fase 2 así que para
esto vamos dibujar pero en esta ocasión
dos células las dos células que me
quedaron de la t la fase 1 así que voy a
poner por aquí mi primera de ellas algo
más o menos así y voy a poner aquí a la
otra de ellas algo muy parecido a esto
aquí tengo mis dos células y entonces en
la profa se dos justo como pasa en la
fase 1 y como pasa en la prov hasta de
la mitosis déjenme notar esto estoy
hablando de la fase 2
c2 la membrana nuclear va a desaparecer
de nuevo así que lo voy a poner de esta
forma la membrana nuclear va a
desaparecer de nuevo lo estoy poniendo
de esta manera y también aquí la
membrana va a desaparecer de nuevo y si
te das cuenta los cromosomas de nuevo se
van a volver a condensar podemos decir
que vuelven a su forma más densa así que
dejan dibujar aquí al primero de ellos
está justo algo así le voy a poner un
poco más largo recuerda que es el
cromosoma largo y al final aquí tiene la
parte de magenta que sale del
entrecruzamiento que se dio en la prov
hace 1 lo voy a poner así por aquí tengo
el pequeño rosado este que está en mi
primera célula está justo aquí y bueno
por acá también tengo a un largo rosado
cromosoma que está condensado no voy a
poner más o menos así déjalo ponerlo así
y bueno este también tienen su parte del
entrecruzamiento
es de color anaranjado y bueno aquí
tengo uno pequeño también de color
anaranjado más o menos algo así estos
genes se condensaron y de hecho cada una
de estas células tendrá centrosomas
duplicados los centrosomas se van a
duplicar y lo voy a poner aquí se van a
poner el primero en un costado de la
célula y después van a migrar en la
siguiente fase así que voy a poner los
centrosomas justo aquí se van a duplicar
y esta fase si te das cuenta es muy
similar a la proffasa de la mitosis
ahora continuemos estamos listos para ir
la siguiente fase es decir la meta fase
2 la
fase 2 en esta ocasión es la número 2 y
para eso voy a dibujar de nuevo a mis
dos células voy a poner a una de ellas
por aquí a algo más o menos así más o
menos así se ve y bueno voy a poner la
otra por acá la otra se ve más o menos
así me gusta está quedando bastante bien
y bueno voy a poner aquí una pequeña
flecha para que veas que estamos pasando
de la prov hace dos a la meta fase 2 de
lujo y ahora en la meta fase 2 lo que va
a pasar es lo siguiente como puedes
imaginar es muy similar a lo que sucede
en la meta fase de la mitosis y de hecho
todo lo que sucede la meiosis 2 es muy
similar a lo que sucede en la mitosis
entonces en la meta fase 2 los
centrosomas migraron a los polos de la
célula por lo tanto voy a tener un
centrosoma por aquí voy a tener otro
centrosoma por aquí voy a tener un
centro soma por aquí y voy a tener otro
centrosoma por aquí aquí
estoy lidiando con dos células ahora y
la membrana nuclear ya desapareció y
entonces los cromosomas empiezan a
migrar hacia el ecuador entonces voy a
dibujar primero a dos cromosomas que
tienen que ver con el color naranja voy
a poner a uno de ellos por aquí estoy
poniendo más o menos algo así aunque le
falta la parte de magenta pero ahorita
lo dibujo porque voy a poner el pequeño
por aquí el pequeño por aquí algo más o
menos así y bueno voy a poner también
los de color magenta aquí me hace falta
esta parte de color rosado y bueno voy a
poner aquí el pequeño justo algo así por
aquí tengo mi pequeño cromosoma y por
aquí voy a poner al largo rosado
cromosoma es más o menos así se va a ver
más o menos así me gusta date cuenta que
ya se están migrando hacia el ecuador y
bueno lo que me hace falta es esta
pequeña parte de color anaranjado algo
así y por supuesto también vamos a estar
llenos de microtúbulos los voy a
continuar haciendo con este color
fijarme en los microtúbulos algo más o
menos así esto también se une con
microtúbulos están algo así y bueno
también por acá tengo microtúbulos y por
acá y voy a hacer lo mismo para esta
célula voy a dibujar por acá
microtúbulos bueno va a jalar algo así
va a jalar algo así y me falta por
ejemplo por acá tengo un montón de
microtúbulos y de hecho estos
microtúbulos están pegados a los
centrosomas están pegados a los
centrosomas pero también están unidos a
los cromosomas están unidos a los
cromosomas en los y neto coros y de
hecho también nos hace falta dibujarlos
centrómeros que son importantes los
centros que son importantes porque date
cuenta que justo aquí tengo las dos
cromáticas hermanas siguen unidas y
entonces tendríamos algo más o menos así
y ahora estamos listos para llegar a la
fase 2 y para eso voy a bajar un poco la
pantalla y vamos a hablar un poco de lo
que pasa en la fase 2
puedes imaginarte lo que va a suceder
las cromáticas hermanas se van a separar
y otra vez esto es muy similar a lo que
sucede en la fase de la mitosis déjame
escribirlo llegamos a la fase 2 a la
anam
2 y en ésta voy a tener dos células
vamos a dibujar mis dos células tengo
una por aquí la voy a hacer más o menos
así algo más o menos así y voy a dibujar
la otra por acá esto me está dejando el
doble de tiempo porque estoy trabajando
con dos células pero aquí están y bueno
voy a dibujar los centrosomas tengo uno
por acá otro por acá otro por acá y el
otro por acá y la clave aquí y es por
esto que se parece mucho a la fase de la
mitosis y no a la fase 1 de la meiosis
justo como en la mitosis las cromáticas
hermanas serán separadas por lo que se
convertirán en dos cromosomas hijos y
bueno estas están conectadas por los
microtúbulos pero se va a ver más o
menos así voy a tener a una de ellas más
o menos por acá se va a ver algo así
algo así lo voy a dibujar voy a dibujar
a otra de ellas por acá esta se va a ver
más o menos así esta es la parte que
tiene un poco de color magenta así que
luego
a poner por acá y bueno también le va a
pasar lo mismo a la pequeña se va a ver
algo más o menos así se va a separar las
dos cromáticas hermanas se van a ir
separando y van a formar a estos
cromosomas a estos cromosomas y éstas
también van a ser caladas en esta
dirección así que lo voy a poner más o
menos así se va a separar algo más o
menos así va a pasar lo mismo con esta
parte esta parte va a ser jalado hacia
este otro polo y bueno ahora le voy a
poner aquí la parte que tengo de color
naranja esta parte de aquí y también va
a jalar al pequeño que tenía de color
anaranjado algo más o menos así y va a
pasar lo mismo de este lado algo más o
menos así
ahora lo voy a llenar todo esto del
microtúbulos porque cada una de estas
cromáticas hermanas ahora será un
cromosoma hijo y bueno entonces los
microtúbulos se verían más o menos así
estos de aquí se cortan y van a ir
calando a esta parte manejando esta otra
parte a esta parte a esta otra parte
aquí voy a dibujar a mis microtúbulos
estos más bien se alargan van a ir
empujando los centrosomas en direcciones
opuestas y con esto van a hacer que se
separen las cromáticas hermanas y
entonces los microtúbulos se van a ver
más o menos así estos están muy
involucrados en todo este trabajo
estos microtúbulos hacen que las cosas
se muevan hacia el lado correcto y esto
pasará también en esta célula y de nuevo
lo que me hace falta son los tiene toco
los recuerdas voy a dibujar por aquí al
2 y neto coros que son importantes aquí
tengo uno aquí falta otro otro por acá
van por ti por acá aquí y por acá de
lujo y ahora ya casi terminamos estamos
listos para movernos hacia la tele fase
vamos a la fase 2 y déjame escribirlo
por acá late
a c2 entonces nos estamos moviendo en
esta dirección y nos vamos a mover
también en esta dirección y en este
momento es donde las dos células se
están convirtiendo ahora en cuatro
células va a suceder la cito sinesis y
se va a ver más o menos así se van a
convertir en cuatro células algo más o
menos así está pasando algo más o menos
así está pasando y de igual manera para
este lado déjenme dibujarlo algo así
algo más o menos así y bueno esta
también se va a separar y se va a ver
más o menos algo así y ahora que se
están separando vamos a tener este
cromosoma el cual se va a ver más o
menos así más o menos así y tienen esta
parte de color magenta esta parte de
color magenta y bueno ahora va este de
aquí este x se ve más o menos así de
hecho lo voy a borrar y voy a poner que
se está desarrollando por lo tanto se va
más o menos así recuerda que en esta
etapa los cromosomas empiezan a
desenrollar van a pasar a su estado de
cromatina este se va a ver más o menos
así es este largo de aquí y bueno
también tengo a esta imagen está que es
este de aquí se va a ver más o menos así
y bueno por aquí también tengo a este
magenta que se va a ver más o menos algo
más o menos así también se está
desarrollando este pequeño cromosoma
color anaranjado tengo este otro pequeño
cromosoma de color anaranjado por acá y
bueno me falta este largo cromosoma de
color magenta que lo voy a poner más o
menos así y le falta la parte en esta
parte de color anaranjado así lo voy a
poner y bueno también la membrana
nuclear empieza a formarse la pueda
poner por aquí la voy a poner también
por acá también la voy a poner por acá
y también le voy a poner por acá y los
microtúbulos empiezan a desaparecer de
hecho estos centros o más también van a
desaparecer pero los voy a dibujar por
acá afuera de nuestra membrana del
núcleo aquí va otro de ellos y por aquí
voy a poner al otro de ellos perfecto y
lo más importante es que está sucediendo
lacito sinesis se están separando estas
células entonces lo voy a poner algo así
porque entonces nuestro resultado final
van a ser cuatro células y cada una de
ellas tiene un número aplauden cada una
de ellas tiene dos cromosomas recuerda
empezamos con una célula con esta que
tenemos acá arriba que era mi célula
germinal la cual tenía un número
diploide igual a 4 en esta célula
tenemos 4 cromosomas dos pares de
cromosomas homólogos y ahora si nos
regresamos nos vamos a dar cuenta que en
esta ocasión tenemos un número a floyd
en en cada uno de estos gametos
resultantes cada uno de ellos de esto
son gametos déjame escribirlo ya que
todos y cada uno de ellos tiene un
número a floyd en pero al inicio es la
meiosis 2 y déjame capturar todo esto
porque todo esto es parte de la meiosis
2 déjame atraparlo lo voy a poner justo
así estuvimos hablando de la meiosis 2 y
para eso le voy a poner nombre todo esto
es parte de la meiosis 2 lo estoy
poniendo justo así le voy a poner aquí
que estábamos trabajando con la
sis
2 justo esto en donde se va a mantener
el número de cromosomas al igual que la
mitosis pero date cuenta que al inicio
de la meiosis 2 habíamos empezado con
células a floyd es también y por esto es
que la meiosis 2 a veces es comparada
con la mitosis pero esta vez empezamos
con un número aplauden y terminamos con
un número aplauden y justo ahora estos
gametos están listos para la
fertilización y es importante que nos
demos cuenta que cada uno de estos
cuatro gametos ahora tiene dos
cromosomas y estos no son cromosomas
homólogos estos codifican para genes
distintos y cada uno de estos gametos
tiene el potencial para fusionarse con
otro gameto y bueno si este
espermatozoide se funcionará con un
óvulo y juntos pueden crear un organismo
que tenga el número completo de pares
homólogos para eso van a servir estos
gametos para la reproducción sexual